je m'appelle à la fin il y a quelques
petites choses que je voudrais préciser
sur moi je souffre de troubles anxieux
je ne peux pas recevoir de visite
je suis agoraphobe je ne peux pas aller
dehors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
mais
vous avez accueilli un élément extérieur
dans votre maison votre voisine d'en
face
je suis à peu près sûr qu'on n'est pas
censée prendre salaire de l'alcool elle
s'appelle jane russell vous êtes devenu
ami avec elle j'aime bien vos boucles
d'oreilles à bercy credo d'un ancien
people
[Musique]
ça ne dérange pas votre mari
notre famille est compliquée et
[Applaudissements]
martin s'était poignardé
pourquoi il est là monsieur russell
pense que vous avez fait vous n'avez
jamais rencontré marc à on a passé la
soirée ensemble
je suis jane russell ce n'est pas james
se fissure de ce que j'ai vu le médecin
indiqué aux médicaments peuvent causer
des hallucinations
pourquoi vous protéger ces gens
ils cachent tous quelque chose
sa boucle d'oreille elle est chez eux
laisser ma famille tranquille
style que vous êtes seul ici
pauli gut je crois qu'il ya quelqu'un
chez moi ne regardez pas ce qui se passe
sur les jambes ça risque de ne pas vous
plaire